for a lot of frustrated gamers this year
was tainted by its many many game delays
various games were delayed for all sorts
of different reasons but here are some
of the biggest that were pushed back and
when you can expect to get your hands on
them first up is a delay that you guys
actually seem pretty willing to forgive
in part probably just because the Devi
is so freaking cool it's the witcher 3
wild hunt CD Projekt RED third entry in
their action RPG series featuring turtle
silver fox Caroll's was supposed to land
sometime toward the end of this year the
devs then decided it was best to push
the release date back to februari 24
year in order to achieve the quality
that their fans expect from one of their
games recently the game was pushed back
again by three months to may have next
year with the dev claiming they don't
want to release a game riddled with bugs
CD Projekt RED have promised something
huge with the witcher 3 an enormous
open-world and a branching narrative
among other features this is one of
those cases where a lot of us would
rather have the game we expect later
than the game that's ready early usually
delays make fans pretty mad but free a
it was probably a better call to delay
battlefield hardline then it was to risk
having a repeat of their launch debacle
with battlefield 4 battlefield hardline
were supposed to land right before the
huge November release period on october
21 instead after a disappointing beta
where gamers who participated suggested
the hardline could stand to be a little
more refined EA pledged to do just that
they announced that the shooter would be
delayed until much 17 of 2015 citing
that they needed more time to fine-tune
and deliver on the narrative this puts
enormous pressure on developer visceral
games to produce a game that doesn't
come off as simply a cops and robbers
battlefield 4 mod and won't replicate
the issues of battlefield 4 the order
1886 was another game slated to come out
in the fall of this year which didn't
quite and make it the ps4 exclusive has
some pretty fancy looking visuals and
even though we still know very little
about the title it turned out to be just
a bit too much for ready at dawn to push
out before the end of 2014 according to
Sony the game is now going to be on
shelves on February 20 of next year
since the dev needs more time to deliver
on promises they made when they debuted
the game at e3 last year as for what
those promises were precisely well they
didn't really say but presumably it's
been pushed to prevent releasing a
lackluster version of their vision yet
another hotly anticipated game that's
moved from an October release date to if
everyone is a symmetric multiplayer game
evolved do you out of every 10 evolve is
brand new IP from the developers of left
4 dead and the level of hype is pretty
damn high so turtle rock studios are
playing this one safe and giving it a
bit more time given how incredibly
important it is for the multiplayer to
be balanced and smooth it's likely the
dev doesn't want to pull a halo master
chief collection and release something
that doesn't work to ease the blow
followers of this one have already been
treated to an alpha across platforms in
October and an xbox one exclusive beta
is jus in January we've been seeing a
lot of this game since its delay but
when Rocksteady initially told us to sit
tight for Batman Arkham Knight it was a
tough pill to swallow the release date
that was October 14 is now set food soon
second Arkham Knight looks insanely cool
and Rocksteady at taking on a lot to
deliver on the visuals and gameplay
they've promised open-world Batmobile
joy rides and all Warner Brothers also
delayed Mad Max and dying light this
year so one would hurt they're doing
something right and not just proving
that they're awful at predicting
realistic development time and finally
is the most superb leave a gray lease
window off the lot the division burst
onto the scene and then fell off the
grid pretty quickly it was pretty
obvious that Ubisoft shooter was not
going to make its fall 2014 release
window particularly after a prior slew
of
you be delays even though we'll be lucky
if this one isn't delayed further it
probably works in ubisoft's favor that
they aren't pulling another watchdogs
delay fiasco by continuously revising
more specific release dates this
third-person social shooter looks
fascinating but right now with anybody's
guess when it's actually going to land
let me know what's your most anticipated
delayed game and if you're expecting it
to live up to the hype I will catch you
next week